bonjour bienvenue à bruxelles au
parlement européen pour un nouveau
numéro d' europe hebdo après les
attentats à paris et saint denis et
maintenant qu'on sait qu'un assaut a été
lancé à saint denis à quelques mètres du
stade de france
plusieurs terroristes neutraliser
maintenant que l'on sait que la plupart
des terroristes sont français maintenant
qu'on sait qu'il s'était presque tous
rendus en syrie
maintenant qu'on sait qu'ils étaient
neufs mais que ni leur préparation ni
leur conversation dont été repéré par
les radars du renseignement français
mais aussi belges maintenant qu'on sait
que ces attentats ont été préparés en
belgique à molenbeek plaque tournante du
terrorisme islamiste
maintenant qu'on sait qu'il y avait un
ou plusieurs terroristes qui étaient de
faux demandeurs d'asile syrien arrivé en
europe via la grèce après les attentats
que peut faire l'europe c'est bien le
sujet de européenne aujourd'hui je vous
propose de commencer cette émission avec
cette image
moment solennel et beaucoup d'émotion
aussi les députés ainsi que le personnel
du parlement européen ont entonné la
marseillaise et ont respecté une minute
de silence à bruxelles comme vous le
voyez pour rendre hommage aux victimes
des attaques à paris président de la
commission européenne jean claude
juncker la haute représentante de
l'union pour les affaires étrangères
frédéric cano guérini et le secrétaire
d'état français chargé des affaires
européennes harlem désir
étaient également présents lors de la
cérémonie le message de martin schulz le
président du parlement européen dans la
douleur nous européens sommes aux côtés
du peuple français
alors avec vous on va essayer de
comprendre s'il ya eu des erreurs des
faiblesses ou une impuissance européenne
direction molenbeek plaque tournante du
terrorisme islamiste
dès l'arrestation liées aux attentats de
paris ont eu lieu dans cette banlieue
bruxelloise connue pour avoir abrité de
nombreux terroristes
françois goulard
molenbeek tous les belges connaissent le
nom de cette commune de la banlieue de
bruxelles et les arrestations qui ont eu
lieu dès le lendemain des attentats de
paris ont conforté sa réputation cette
ville très pauvres touchés de plein
fouet par le chômage est une des bases
européennes du terrorisme islamiste
c'est une commune d'abord qui est une
commune relativement populaire en tout
cas pour certains de ses quartiers avec
une population issue de l'immigration
qui est à peu près de 50% en moyenne et
dans cette population une frange
radicale pas très importante on parle de
quelques pour cent mais réel et depuis
des années c'est à dire depuis 20 ou 30
ans on a donc vu s'installer à noël bec
des gens qui sont devenus des espèces de
chef de file de l'islamisme radical
non seulement de lui en europe la figure
la plus connue de ces islamistes de
molenbeek
c'est lui abdelhamid abou oud chef de la
cellule terroriste de verviers démantelé
en janvier 2015
il est d'ailleurs impliqué dans la
préparation des attentats de pâques
mais la liste ne s'arrête pas là le
français mehdi né mouche l'auteur de l'
attaque contre le musée juif de
bruxelles en mai 2014 est passé par
molenbeek
tout comme le jeune marocain ayoub el
khazani qui a mené l attaque dans le
thalys en août dernier face à ce foyer
de djihadistes le gouvernement belge
assure qu'il va frapper fort cash back
up je vais faire le ménage à molenbeek
je vais regarder pourquoi ça ne va pas
là-bas et comment on peut faire pour
arranger les choses
ça ne peut plus durer il faut trouver
une solution à ce problème problème
en paca le problème de la radicalisation
ne concerne pas que molenbeek
mais toute la belgique le pays produit
le plus de combattants islamistes
d'europe dans ce petit état de 11
millions d'habitants 494 jihadistes ont
été identifiés par les autorités dont
272 sont en irak ou en syrie et 134 sont
revenus autant de menaces potentielles
pour la belgique mais aussi pour
l'europe
alors nous enjoint sur ce plateau sylvie
goulard bonjour vous êtes eurodéputé
membre de l'alliance des démocrates et
des libéraux un élu sous les couleurs du
modem vous vous réclamez la création
d'un fbi européen
on y reviendra en face de vous philippe
lambertz eurodéputés belges du groupe
les verts on vient de voir le sujet de
françois goulard des attentats à paris
mais des hordes qui seraient venus de
belgique est syrie est ce que la
belgique est une plaque tournante du
terrorisme islamiste
c'est clair qu'il y à des cellules
terroristes qui réside en belgique ce
n'est pas ce n'est pas une grande
nouveauté
quand on parle d'un big band des buttes
chaumont là c'est plutôt en france
lorsqu'on parle de certains quartiers de
londres c'est plutôt au royaume uni on
sait que au sein même de l'europe il ya
un certain nombre d'endroits où des
cellules terroristes ont prospéré les
attentats de 2001 était plutôt partie
d'hambourg en allemagne
donc oui ce sont des choses qui existent
et auxquels il faut s'attaquer
ce que je constate c'est que a dans la
plupart des cas observés
les terroristes sont des citoyens de nos
pays 2 que la plupart d'entre aide est
connu des services de police mais que en
règle générale le renseignement dont
nous disposions était n'était d'une part
pas communiquer entre les différents
services de police parfois à l'intérieur
d'un même état est certainement entre
les états et par ailleurs qu' il manque
des ressources pour exploiter ces
renseignements c'est à dire mettre ces
gens se surveillant ce qui me revient de
mes conversations avec les services de
police
ce n'est pas que nous manquons de
renseignements mais bien que au manque
de ressources pour exploiter le
renseignement c'est à dire mettre ces
gens sous surveillance il joue là il ya
un manque de coordination entre les
services français et les services belges
je crois pas que le problème soit
seulement une question de coordination
faut d'abord expliquer aux
téléspectateurs une chose simple
l'illusion du territoire gouverné par un
état sur lequel il ya une autorité et
les personnes qui sont une menace pour
cet état se trouve sur ce territoire
malheureusement ce n'est plus comme ça
c'est pas une question de le vouloir ou
pas c'est une réalité
les terroristes sont mobiles de même que
le climat est une menace qui vient
d'ailleurs donc l'organisation de nos
états n'est probablement pas adaptée au
monde dans lequel la lutte contre le
terrorisme c'est une compétence
nationale ce sont les états mais qu'est
ce que ça veut dire vous pouvez répéter
juridiquement que c'est une compétence
nationale
av 200 morts à paris comme le week-end
dernier donc moi ce qui m'intéresse
c'est pas de défendre des structures
juridiques c'est de trouver des
solutions
il est évident que nous pourrions aller
bien au delà de la coordination qui est
bien sûr la première étape mais chacun
sait que la coordination ne marche pas
bien
il ya même pas de bonne coordination
parfois entre les différents services de
police d'un même pays
donc ce qu'il faut c'est franchir un
certain nombre d'étapes met de la
confiance pour que l'information
disponible circulons réfléchir aux
moyens nous avons collectivement voulu
donner la sécurité
tous ces gens qui maintenant font le
virage sécuritaire en février 2013 quand
le budget européen a été adopté pour les
sept années qui viennent est-ce qu'ils
ont placé la sécurité le terrorisme en
tête de leurs priorités
non on a fait quoi on a fait un budget
du passé dans lequel l'essentiel c'est
la politique agricole commune et les
fonds structurels
donc il ya un jour où il faut aussi
assumer que si on veut faire des choses
ensemble au niveau européen il faut des
moyens juridiques et des moyens
matériels et financiers sur la belgique
et l organisation non gouvernementale la
plus importante du monde a pas de
gouvernement pendant adresse que ça pas
jouer en ce moment dans ce manque de
coordination des polices non je ne crois
pas ou de communication des informations
je vous rappelle que la belgique a
toujours eu un gouvernement simplement
pendant 500 jours on a eu un
gouvernement en affaires courantes qui
ne veut pas dire pour autant que les
services de police ne fonctionnait pas
que la justice ne fonctionnait pas dans
ce pays maintenant de nouveaux avons
nous mis suffisamment de moyens sur la
surveillance de ces individus qui sont
connus des services de police qui sont
revenus ce que je constate c'est que
même l'administration municipale et la
zone de police de molenbeek n'a pas
toujours les informations sur les gens
qui sont revenus l'irak parce que ces
informations sont détenues par la sûreté
de l'état
un autre service de police en belgique
et que comme le disait sylvie et bien
parfois les information ne circule pas
vraiment très bien entre les différents
services et donc la belgique n'a pas été
laxiste alors sur le coup est-ce qu'elle
a été laxiste en tout cas elle n'a pas
mis les moyens suffisants pour exploiter
les renseignements dont on disposait à
nouveau nous avions le renseignement il
fallait peut être exploité manière un
petit peu plus ambitieuse mais là je
pense en effet qu'il nous faut peut-être
une source de police fédérale européenne
si nous voulons pouvoir s'attaquer à une
menace qui est qui nous touche tous en
europe alors on va essayer de répondre à
cette question comment l'union
européenne lutter contre le terrorisme
l'europe elle a des outils revue de
détail et ont réagi juste après
en europe la lutte contre le terrorisme
reste avant tout une compétence
nationale
mais face à la recrudescence des
attentats une coordination européenne a
été mise en place à voici les principaux
outils de l'europe dans la lutte contre
le terrorisme
le système d'information schengen à ce
fichier informatique européen permet aux
services responsables des contrôles aux
frontières policiers et douaniers et aux
autorités judiciaires d'un état schengen
de disposer de données sur des personnes
signalées et des objets véhicule
recherché le mandat d'arrêt européen à
la suite des attentats du 11 septembre
2001 la procédure du mandat d'arrêt
européen est adopté pour faciliter
l'extradition de personnes condamnées
d'un état membre à un autre
enfin le registre des passagers aériens
c'est le dossier sensible le pnr été
créés aux états unis à la suite des
attentats de 2001
il s'agit d'un ensemble de données
collectées par les compagnies aériennes
lors de la réservation d'un vol ou de
l'enregistrement
ça marche pour les vols en direction des
états unis
ça ne fonctionne toujours pas en europe
le partage des données des passagers
aériens entre les différents pays
d'europe est toujours freiné cette
attentatoires aux libertés individuelles
disent les écologistes européens
aujourd'hui
le ton est monté d'un cran face aux
attentats le président français pose ses
exigences à l'europe
il est également impératif que les
demandes que la france a exprimé depuis
longtemps trouvent en europe une
traduction rapide
je pense à la lutte contre le trafic
d'armes à la mise en place des contrôles
coordonnés et systématiques aux
frontières et à l'approbation avant la
fin de l'année 2015 de ce qu'on appelle
le pnr europe 1 européen tout simplement
pour assurer la traçabilité du retour
des djihadistes et des interpellés voilà
les exigences
l'espace schengen c'est 400 millions de
ressortissants
avec schengen ces pays ont supprimé les
contrôles systématiques à leurs
frontières intérieures mais impose des
contrôles aux frontières extérieures
40000 km de frontières maritimes et 8000
kilomètres de frontière terrestre avec
les attentes à une réforme du dispositif
schengen est actuellement discuté par
les états notamment sur la question du
rétablissement des contrôles aux
frontières nationales
voilà on a vu un peu les outils dont
dispose l'europe dans la lutte contre le
terrorisme
il ya une pomme de discorde le pnr
impasse hadjar name record c'est
l'enregistrement des noms des passagers
dans les compagnies aériennes pour
vulgariser c'est un fichier nous
permettant de savoir qui prend l'avion
le pnr le parlement européen ferait de
la résistance sur ce projet les écolos
sont pas d'accord françois hollande veut
que ce soit mise en place rapidement que
l'europe se réveille c'est pour quand le
pnr pourquoi ça bloque
sylvie goulard d'abord ça ne bloque pas
contrairement à ce qu'on dit à paris les
discussions sont en cours deuxièmement
le parlement européen la résistance
quand même du parlement
oui mais pour de bonnes raisons mais il
faut que chacun assume ce qu'a été son
rôle dans cette affaire
l'idée c'est quoi on fait un fichier de
données vous avez vu l'émotion que
suscite une décision de la cour de
justice qui protège nos données le
parlement européen a voulu protéger les
citoyens européens pas dire on ne fait
pas le pnr dire si on fait un pnr si on
fait des interconnexions de fichiers on
a apporté un certain nombre de garant
des protégés de quoi alors c'est une
dalle ips et attentatoire aux libertés
individuelles en droit français comment
dans le droit de la plupart des états
membres toute la collection de données
reposent sur un certain nombre de règles
on ne peut pas constituer des fichiers
pourquoi parce qu'on veut pas faire un
fichier des juifs on va pas faire un
fichier des arabes
on veut pas faire un fichier des gens
qui n'aiment pas telle ou telle chose
donc c'est un risque majeur pour les
libertés
ça ne veut pas dire qu'il faut pas le
faire ça veut dire qu'il faut faire
quand on va aux etats-unis le pnr sa
page mais les américains peuvent voter
toutes les lois qu'ils veulent ils ont
fait quand un amant aussi chez bien
qu'en france en ce moment il ya des gens
qui veulent faire quand un amour il
américain c'est les américains et
l'europe est souveraine dans ses
décisions des libertés publiques
c'est en europe qui a eu la shoah c'est
en europe qu'il faut qu'on fasse
attention à un certain nombre de dérives
encore une fois les négociations sont en
cours le parlement européen avait rejeté
une première
en version la commission européenne
pouvait revenir plus vite avec un texte
la france en 2013 pouvait à ce moment-là
venir avec des exigences
donc il ne s'agit pas pour le président
de la république d'un pays et encore une
fois ce pays est sous le choc c'est le
mien je comprends sa réaction mais de
fixer les dates aux autres il s'agit de
trouver ensemble un système qui soit à
la fois efficaces pour collecter les
données mais dans lequel il ya un
certain nombre de garanties qui permette
que ça se passe bien pour des pour
éviter que ces fichiers qui serait
récupéré même ne se reste de manière
frauduleuse
puis servir à des fins qui ne seraient
pas des fins correct philippe lambert si
vous êtes écologistes c'est votre groupe
pac qui ne veut pas que le pnr et goûter
si c'était avec mon groupe qui pèse 50
députés sur 550
je pense que ce serait nous faire
beaucoup d'honneur de nous dire que nous
sommes capables à nous tous seuls de
bloquer un dossier européen tous les
arguments que sylvie a développées sont
parfaitement fondées
il ya un principe de base en démocratie
c'est la proportionnalité entre la
restriction liberté ici la collecte
généralisée l'information est l'objectif
recherché
la question qu'il faut se poser c'est
ignorions nous la nature fait l'identité
de ceux qui ont commis des actes
terroristes cette année c'est en france
avant ça en espagne en italie en
belgique au royaume-uni etc
la réponse est non ce type étaient
connus dont convient par un dire qu'il
fallait qu'on puisse les repérer ils
étaient repérés ils étaient repérés donc
le pnr en l'occurrence n'aurait servi à
rien du tout ces types sont venus en
voiture en métro mais pas du tout par
l'avion alors bien sûr ici l'avion
depuis son annonce il y est bien on les
a repérés
donc on n'a pas eu besoin d'un pnr
européen pour les repérer c'est ce que
je constate
et donc on voudrait nous faire croire
qu'en ce qui vous fait peur dans le pnr
et c'est pas une question de faire peur
c'est une question de principe
veuillez trouvez vous normal que toutes
les données de tous les passagers de
tous les vols qui circulent en europe
soient collectées sans aucun mandat
judiciaire est fourni en vrac aux
services de police
c'est là quelque chose qui en fait est
complètement disproportionnée par
rapport à l'objectif recherché à nouveau
quand je discute avec des policiers qui
sont actifs sur le terrain ils nous
disent en général
le pnr nous sert à posteriori pour
tracer l'itinéraire des gens et lorsque
nous avons des suspicions c'est sûr des
gens identifiés leurs familles leurs
proches et
nous sommes capables de cibler les
données dont nous avons besoin moi je
n'ai absolument aucun problème pour que
sur une base ciblées et avec mandat
judiciaire les données soient collectées
aucun problème mais nous n'avons pas
besoin de collecter massivement et
généralement les dom est ce qu'on sera
incapable de les exploiter ciblées -
chose qui me fascine c'est vous voyez le
nombre de gens de millions de gens qui
prennent l'avion
donc je crois qu'il faut raison garder
en ce moment où elle a vraiment essayé
de trouver des solutions c'est qu'on est
tombé dans le trop sécuritaire et qu'on
ne réfléchit pas et en tout cas on
réagit moment de maintenir un certain
nombre de principes sinon ce sont les
terroristes qui garait nous faire peur
si nous paniquons c'est eux qui gagnent
donc dans tous nos pays ça a été rappelé
par philippe lambert
il y à un principe c'est que la police
agit en principe sauf état d'urgence
j'ai soutenu le président de république
dans sa décision la dans ces
circonstances-là de déclarer l'état
d'urgence mais c'est l'exception
mais le principe normal c'est que quand
des opérations de police ont lieu elles
ont lieu sous le contrôle d'un magistrat
proche d'où la nécessité d'avoir un
parquet européen
je reviens à l'instant dans votre
reportage vous parliez du mandat d'arrêt
européen
il se trouve que j'étais auprès du
président romano prodi président la
commission en 2001 au moment des
attentats du 11 septembre
depuis des mois et des années la
commission européenne européenne disait
doutons nous de cet outil par exemple à
l'époque et dieu sait si c'était 106
pour l' affaire dutroux
parce que vous alliez des pédophiles
vous avez des gens qui s'engouffre dans
les brèches de la construction
européenne actuelle qui sont pas les
gens sympathiques terroristes
aujourd'hui pédophiles hier nous
plaidions à la commission européenne
pour que ce dossier avance les etam en
disait non si j'ose dire c'est grâce aux
attentats du 11 septembre pour avoir une
annonce à faire pour dire qu'il faisait
quelque chose et alors que ça n'avait
aucun rapport avec les attendent à
durance à blanc que les gouvernements
l'ont acceptée alors est-ce que le temps
en temps on pourrait agir en amont avant
qu'il est victime avant qu'ils les
personnes qui meurent et là les
questions qu'il faut se poser c'est on a
besoin de gardes côtes aux frontières
comment les organismes
on a besoin bien entendu de circulation
d'informations pnr et autres comment
l'organisent on a besoin d'une police
fédérale européenne comment on organise
et pas de toujours ré
j revoir sur réagir aux élèves sylvie
boulard le président la république a dit
qu'ils allaient invoquer un article 1 du
traité de l'union européenne article 42
sat qui prévoit la solidarité des
européens
lorsqu'en tapei en fait et agressé
qu'est ce qu'elle va donner cette
initiative concrète alors d'un côté je
n'ai aucun doute que nos partenaires
vont exprimer leur solidarité simplement
il faut se mettre à la place des autres
la plupart des pays d'europe n'ont pas
contrairement à la france la même
tradition militaire et non pas été
frappée récemment par des attentats
aussi cruel il y avait une autre base
juridique dans le traité qui est une
base juridique spécifique pour le
terrorisme qui est l'article 222 du
traité et qui permettait un jeu
institutionnel plus large c'est à dire
c'était pas la france demande aux autres
et à un soutien militaire c'était
l'union européenne avec la force de ses
institutions
avec l'information de ce parlement
l'union européenne est au tour de la
france je pense que l'europe dans le
théâtre des opérations extérieures est
aux abonnés absents un peu mais quand
vous voulez faire si c'est marrant n'y a
pas de politique étrangère et de
sécurité
les affaires étrangères mais une fois
vous avez affirmé ça vous avez dit quoi
moi ce qui m'intéresse c'est pas de
réaffirmer toujours les mêmes choses et
je vous en veux pas à vous c'est quelque
chose qu'on entend partout à paris tenus
mais ça c'est un constat c'est pas un
constat qui permet l'action moi ce que
je vous dis c'est que la france avait le
choix entre deux bases juridiques lune
qui est une coopération entre états
l'autre et sur un plan militaire l'autre
qui est une coopération qui inclut les
institutions sur un fondement de lutte
contre le terrorisme
je dis simplement et sans vouloir
critiquer bêtement le président de
république mais que la deuxième base
juridique me paraissait plus fondées
pourquoi parce que dans les pays dans
lesquels n'y a pas de tradition
militaire dans les pays dans les pays
c'aurait été plus facile plus rassurant
et donc comme ça on aurait pu les amener
à bouger moi mon but c'est de faire
bouger les autres pays c'est pas juste
de leur balancer à la figure vous êtes
des nains politiques et vous voulez pas
avancer parce que ça c'est pas très
constructif
alors dans son discours un martin schulz
a rendu hommage aux victimes des
attentats à paris à saint-denis
mais le président du parlement européen
a mis en garde un conte fasse pas de
l'amalgamé entre réfugiés syriens ou
irakiens et terroristes on écoute et on
réagit juste après
les attentats de paris était une attaque
contre notre liberté
une attaque contre nos valeurs
européennes et notre mode de vie une
attaque contre nous tous dans la douleur
nous européens sommes aux côtés du
peuple français
nous sommes unis nous ne nous laisserons
pas un poids zone et par le veinard de
ces criminels si nous suspectons tous
les réfugiés de syrie alors nous
confondons victimes et meurtrière car
les réfugiés et cherche précisemment
chez nous un asile contre la barbarie de
ces assassins
alors on a découvert après les attentats
que un ou plusieurs terroristes étaient
deux fous demandeurs d'asile syrien
arrivé en grèce via orient en europe via
la grèce est ce que le risque de voir
des terroristes partager le trajet des
migrants venus de syrie et d'irak est
réel ou c'est un fantasme philippe
lambert ce alors première chose il faut
raison garder on a trouvé un passeport
on ne sait pas si ce passeport est vrai
ou faux peu importe que ne sautons pas
aux conclusions
est ce qu'il est possible à des gens mal
intentionnés de s'infiltrer dans un flux
de réfugiés
la réponse est oui est il possible à des
terroristes d'arriver en europe sans
passer par là la réponse est 10 fois oui
parce que pour à une personne suspectée
d'être passé par le canal des réfugiés
ce qu'on constate c'est que tous ceux
qui ont commis les attentats à nouveau à
bruxelles à paris à londres à madrid
sont les gens qui vivaient ici qui sont
partis en syrie qui sont revenus non pas
par un afflux de réfugiés parce qu'à
l'époque il n'existait pas mais bien par
des voies tout à fait normal donc qu'on
s'imagine fait s'imaginer que en mettant
une barrière à l'accès des réfugiés en
euros on va régler le problème c'est à
nouveau se mentir et comme le disait
sylvie tout à l'heure et bien dans des
situations comme celle-ci ce qu'on
constate c'est que bien souvent les
gouvernements veux simplement donner
l'impression qu'ils font quelque chose
j'appelle ça de la gesticulation et donc
donner l'impression qu'on règle le
problème en en faisant des déclarations
outrancières c'est ce qu'on entend en
pologne et ailleurs ou en prenant des
mesures en prenant des mesures qui en
fait ne sont pas des réponses aux
problèmes et à nouveau je voudrais
vraiment comme sylvie plaidé pour que
nous gardions raison que nous essayons
de regarder ce qui n'a pas concrètement
marché est de nouveau c'est
principalement l'exploitation du
renseignement plutôt que la question des
réfugiés
justement en gala merkel et françois
hollande avait demandé à la création de
hotspots un de centres de regroupement
dans les pays où les réfugiés arrivent
pour précisément les enregistrer pour
savoir qui est véritablement demandeur
d'asile qui migrants économiques et qui
a éventuellement terroristes en
puissance
est ce que cette politique se concrétise
si le goût là d'après les informations
que j'ai moi je ne suis pas dans ces
hotspots mais il me semble bien que les
allemands font une différence à mon avis
justifiée entre des personnes
ils sont qui ont été obligés de quitter
des territoires en guerre je rappelle
qu'en syrie la situation est effroyable
que les troupes de l'isis justement font
des exactions d exécution et on devrait
un peu moins se polariser sur nos morts
toutes les victimes sont des gens à
défend donc les femmes yézidie qui ont
été violées réduite à l'esclavagé sexuel
et c'est dans ces régions là sont des
victimes
donc d'abord ces deux sont des zones
dangereuses ces gens là ont une urgence
il est évident que si en passant par la
serbie l'albanie etc se rajoutent des
personnes qui bon veulent simplement
améliorer leur vie mais ne sont pas
menacées dans leur existence il faut
arriver à faire quelque chose d'assez
abominable qui intrigue mais il faut
quand même y arriver est en tout cas
l'allemagne y est fermement décidé
ensuite là encore moi je suis toujours
prudente parce que comme l'a dit
philippe on peut promettre aux gens
qu'on va arriver à faire des choses et
puis une fois que les émissions vont se
calmer moi ce que j'espère si vous allez
faire des émissions sur la réponse
européenne dans la durée où on sera dans
ces années là pour çà se lancera dans un
an mais oui mais c'est important parce
qu'on l'a bien vu après charlie on a
toute une vague d'émotion démission et
après le sujet repasse au deuxième plan
donc il faut arriver à faire ça il faut
renvoyer éventuellement dans des pays
sur les gens qui viennent de pays sûrs
et il faut aussi trouver une solution à
la fois diplomatique et militaire pour
que ce gigantesque camp d'entraînement
que la syrie ne continue pas à contacter
former des gens qui viennent chez nous
mais il ya quand même une problème qu'on
ne peut pas pardon parce que ces
problèmes c'est ces attentats ne posent
pas la question du du contrôle des
frontières est ce qu'on va revenir en
arrière schengen à venir contrôler nos
frontières intérieures
non écoutez ça aurait tranché ça aurait
si je ne sais même pas si c'est
matériellement possible vu les flux de
camions qui passent entre le luxembourg
et la france vous avez 70 milles
journalier ce qui se passera c'est qu'au
bout d'un moment les lèvres à ces
contrôles donc il est beaucoup plus
efficace encore une fois comme je les
dis de créer pourquoi il ya des
conséquences économiques de la santé au
sens économique la durée hier soir
j'avais une amie belge qui était allé
voir sa mère qui m'a dit qu'elle avait
mis une heure et demie à franchir la
frontière française
parce que les fermes et parce qu'il ya
des contrôles entre l'italie
la france donc encore une fois ce sont
des mesures qu'on peut comprendre dans
une situation exceptionnelle pour
traquer un individu à long terme ya une
autre question il ya une autre question
moi que je veux soulever c'est qu'il ya
aussi un échec de nos relations avec les
populations musulmanes de nationalité
française belge et c'est qu'ils vivent
sur nos territoires ce qui se dit dans
certaines mosquées n'est pas compatible
avec les règles de ces pays
c'est pas un jugement de valeur c'est se
prend profondément juridique de même que
on a à s'attaquer à l'avancé mosquée
écoutez il ya une vidéo qui circule sur
youtube je sais pas si elle est exacte
ou pas on voit un imam à brest des
femmes de grèce alpha
voilà un dire à des enfants que la
musique est satanique et on voit bien le
lien si vous mettez dans la tête
d'enfants de 10 ou 12 ans que parce
qu'ils écoutent de la musique qui vont
se transformer en cochon en singe dans
quelques années vous aurez peut-être des
candidats allaient porter la mangue au
bataclan
la musique est une activité pacifique
dans nos pays est autorisée c'est en
plus un des arts les plus beaux que nous
ayons il faut que nous clarifions ce
genre de questions et je suis sûr
personnellement que l'immense majorité
des musulmans évidemment ne voit pas
dans la musique l'objet d'une
transformation en singe ou un cochon
mais comment avons nous laissé ces
gens-là proliférer et et pouvoir donner
leur discours en toute quiétude dans nos
lieux de culte encore une fois la
liberté de culte est temps aussi garanti
en france mais s'il faut permettre sans
aller jusque là qu'est ce que je
constate c'est que nous sommes tous
horrifiés est vraiment remuer jusqu'au
tréfonds notre âme en voyant les images
des attentats de paris mais souvent dans
notre population d'origine musulmane
nous avons à ce moment là des jeunes qui
nous montre les images de femmes
d'enfants de civils tués par des
bombardements à gaza au yémen en syrie
en irak en afghanistan et en effet
s'imaginer qu'on peut faire la guerre
propre c'est évidemment une vaste
fumisterie mais la touche un gain ou
penser qu'on va revenir en arrière qu'on
va fermer en doute mais les frontières
comme ces demandes et on voit bien qu'il
y a énormément gesticulations dans ce
sens là je pense tout comme sylvie que
ça n'est pas une réponse ce qu'il faut
lehman aurait fait ce pour quoi mais
lorsque vous allez empêcher 70000
personnes avaient eu lieu sans gourde
aller travailler et que ça n'empêchera
pas
cinglé de passer avec une kalachnikov
vrai sujet c'est efficace même si on
peut rêver d'arrêter tous les gens
qu'est ce qu'on va faire on va
durablement empêcher tout tout mouvement
population et puis si un jour il ya un
nid de djihadistes à toulouges envoie
qu'est ce qu'on va faire on va en cercle
et toulouse on va empêcher les gens
d'aller de toulouse à paris
ça n'a aucun sens n'ont par contre il
faut absolument mettre des moyens dans
l'identification des suspects et dans
leur mise sous surveillance je suis
désolé soyons ciblé ciblons ceux qui
sont véritablement les adversaires et
mettons les sous surveillance et plus
pour les empêcher de nuire ce que la
tunisie pourrait même avoir moins de
moyens pour surveiller les gens qu'il
faut sur l'île de man surveillance
financière s'assurer rit énormément de
gens qui eux sont totalement inoffensifs
sylvie goulard philippe lambert merci
d'avoir accepté notre invitation elle
vous propose de terminer avec une note
de violon après les attaques terroristes
qui ont semblé ensanglanté paris le
parlement européen a rendu hommage aux
victimes habitant les eurodéputés à se
recueillir durant un adagio de jean
sébastien bach jouée par une violoniste
ukrainienne écoutez bonne suite des
programmes
bye bye
lee
les